Being able to reach out to your
developers is an invaluable asset to
having a popular API.
Having blogs and forums allow back and
forth communications between client side
and server side developers, creating
a community around your product.
Publishing content via social media and
having code available on GitHub is also
a great way to accumulate followers and
evangelists for your product.
And even when things go wrong,
developers respect a company
that doesn't go into hiding, but rather,
openly communicates major bugs and
outages, so that they can
respond quickly and accordingly.
So, as you're making your own APIs,
make sure there's still a component for
human communication in order
to better support your users.